hey guys it's Rob and welcome to my
tutorial for thee transforming ninja
star I got a bunch of requests on my
last video for the transforming ninja
star and I could see why it's a really
cool fun and it's also an easy model to
make it's a type of modular origami
model where you're going to be
interlocking or joining eight of these
small modular units together in order to
get the ninja star each one is identical
and they're each very similar to making
the water bomb base what you're going to
need is a small square pieces of paper
I'm going to be using these sheets that
I got from Staples they're all different
colors and these work really well for
making the transforming star you can
also use post-it notes like these these
work really well you'll get something
that comes out pretty much the same it's
a little bit smaller
once you have eight small pieces of
square paper you're ready to begin to
get your transforming ninja star so that
it has alternating colors like mine does
you're going to want to use four sheets
of one color and four sheets of another
color it doesn't really matter I just
like the way it looks but you can use
one color if you want as I said it's
very similar to making the water bomb
base I'm going to go through with you
how to make two of them and then I'll
also show you real quick how to do with
the post-it notes grab one of the sheets
and we're going to basically make it
like a water bomb base so you're going
to take one corner and fold it across to
the other corner
make a crease and you can run your
fingernail against it because it doesn't
matter if you are kneed it helps it out
a little bit so now that we have a
diagonal fold going this way we're going
to take the other corner and fold it to
the opposite corner
and make another crease so now if you
open up the paper you should have an X
in it and then we're going to take one
edge of the paper and fold it across to
the other edge
so now if you open up the paper you
should have an X and a horizontal line
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to position this line in the
middle so that it is vertical and we're
going to take both of the top corners
and we're going to fold it inwards onto
that vertical line so that the top edge
here is on the vertical line so just
take the corner fold it inwards onto
that vertical line just like that and
make a crease do the same with the other
top edge
so you should have something that looks
just like this now what we're going to
do is we're going to fold the paper in
half like this
and now you have this other corner of
the paper and what you're going to do is
if you remember the waterbomb base we're
going to basically tuck this this corner
in just like that
so just take the other end here the edge
and you're going to tuck it in words to
the bottom just like that and now you
have these two flaps on the right side
tuck it in and then make the crease so
that's basically how you make each of
the modular units it's very simple so
I'm going to do it real quick with the
blue one now same thing fold it to
corner
opposite corner to opposite corner same
thing
fold one edge to the opposite edge
then open it up hold that center line
here vertically and then just fold the
top corners into that line
just like that then fold the model in
half like this
and then you're going to tuck this other
corner on the right side in towards the
center tuck it all the way in and then
close these two flaps that you now have
and make a crease and that's how you
make the modular unit so you should be
able to make the remaining six so what I
do with the post-it note is I peel it
off and I've marked where it's sticky
and you're going to hold that sticky
edge on the back then you're going to do
the two diagonal folds just like that
and now when you're going to make the
edge to edge fold I like to cut this
sticky edge in half by holding it
vertically on the back like this then
you fold the top edge down to the bottom
edge and I'll show you why I do that
it's because once you have made this
fold and you're going to fold the edges
in you're going to fold them in on the
sticky edge so that the two top corners
get stuck to the paper just like that
you see fold the corners in
fold it in half and now the same thing
just tuck this corner in here
and there you go interlocking the first
seven units is pretty much the same
exact thing it's really not that
difficult it's the last piece that might
be a little tricky so I'll focus mainly
on how to connect the last piece what
you're going to want to do is to first
set them up if you're using alternating
colors you're going to want to take two
different color units and you're going
to basically hold them like we just
finished creating them so you want these
two flaps on the right and you want the
two corners which you fold it in to be
on the left side just like this hold the
piece on the right the same exact way
then you'll see we have these edges here
right you want to have these two flaps
open and you're going to take this edge
here and you're going to twist it so
that it is completely vertical and then
you're going to slide the piece on the
right into the piece on the left until
this corner here is basically right in
between the top of those flaps right
there and you want to make sure that
this edge is all the way seated into the
piece on the left just like that now
when you do that you'll see you have a
little bit of excess sticking over the
piece on the right and what you're going
to do is you're going to basically pull
the piece down that's in front of you
and you're going to fold this excess
towards you over the right piece just
like that and then make a crease along
the top then you can unfold it now what
you're going to do is the same thing
with the top flap hold this one back and
then fold this one over the right piece
now you'll see you have made two creases
and what you're going to do now is
you're going to open the two flaps on
the right piece now and you're going to
tuck these tips into it just like that
and then what you're going to do is just
close these two flaps on the right now
and just give it a good crease so now
you'll see you will be able to slide
these two pieces within each other
so now you're going to do the same thing
with the piece on the right you're going
to go in a clockwise direction in other
words you're not going to add to the
left you're going to add to the right so
grab another piece hold it this way
rotate it so that this opening here is
vertical just like that slide it into
the piece on the right and put the tip
at the the top here now you can slide it
down here and if it's easier for you
then you could do it like that meaning
it doesn't have to be perfectly lined up
like that but you do want it like that
in the end so if you want to slide it
like that as long as you have it seated
properly meaning as long as this edge is
all the way in it'll be fine
so then do the same thing fold this one
back and take the excess here and fold
it over the piece on the right that
you're adding and make a crease unfold
it then just move away the back piece
and fold the top flap here over the new
piece that you're adding and you're
always folding in towards the center of
these flaps so you're folding this one
like this towards you and this one away
from you then once you've made those
creases you can open the flaps on the
right and you could tuck these tips in
just like that now being that I didn't
tuck them in at the corner here I just
want to slide the new piece all the way
to the end like that and that's
basically how you're going to interlock
them so I'm going to skip ahead to the
seventh piece when you get to the
seventh and eighth pieces you'll notice
that the units will start to overlap but
they're interlocked the same way take
the tip of the seventh piece and slide
it in between the two flaps of the sixth
piece and also make sure that the tip is
also going in between these two flaps
that you previously tucked in you don't
want to slide this underneath there like
that otherwise you'll have problems
sliding it past one another in the end
make sure that it's in between there
just like that
now I've already creased it here but you
guys know what to do so just take the
tips
of the sixth piece and tuck them into
the two flaps of the seventh piece just
like that also and you're going to take
the tip of the first piece here and
you're going to bring it so that it's in
between the two flaps of the seventh
piece now grab the eighth piece and just
open the flaps of the seventh piece a
little bit just like that and you're
going to do the same thing take the two
flaps of the eighth piece now and make
sure that the tip of the first piece
slides into the two flaps there and
you're going to take the tip of the
eighth piece and just kind of push the
whole piece down like that so that the
tip also goes in between the two flaps
of the seven piece just like that okay
so now it should be in there make sure
that the tips are properly in between
the two flaps like this and then all
you're going to do is also interlock
these tips here
so you guys know how to make these
creases fold that back take the back one
fold it towards you now what's a little
bit different is that you already have a
tip in between the two flaps you do not
want to take the tip here and fold it
over the tip nope you want it to be only
over this flap of this of the eighth
piece so you want to take the tip of the
seventh piece and tuck it right in there
okay just like that do the same with the
back flap
so just make sure that you're not going
over that tip like that because if you
do you're not going to be able to slide
this piece out okay that's important so
take that tip and put it on the side
like that you're going to do the same
with the tips of the eighth eighth piece
fold it back and then what you're going
to do you're just going to have to open
these two flaps here on the first piece
and you're going to tuck it in there on
the side open the flap and you're going
to tuck it on side of that tip just like
that so it should look just like that
before you go to transform the ninja
star just double-check that none of the
tips or blades are being covered by any
of these side flap tips then all you
need to do is to grab two opposite
pieces and push them directly towards
each other until the blades have come
out rotate it and do the same thing
until all the blades have been revealed
and there you go you have a transforming
ninja star thanks for watching my
tutorial for the transforming ninja star
if you like the video be sure to click
the thumbs up or like button below and
subscribe by clicking the subscribe
button above also if you leave me a
comment in the comment section I might
feature it in my next video so be sure
to let me know what you guys thought
just one more thing I need to show you
guys how to throw it to throw the
transforming ninja star in the frisbee
or octagon configuration you're going to
want to hold it just like a frisbee but
you're going to angle it like that and
then just want to flick your wrist
outwards I've found with the ninja star
configuration if you throw it like a
frisbee or even if you angle it like
that it's always gonna wind up landing
vertically like this and it will damage
the tips a little bit so I find it the
best just to throw it vertically like
that